[Music]
by this second aspect of the moral view
of the world the other assertion of the
first aspect in which the disharmony of
morality and happiness is assumed is
also nullified it has claimed that
experience shows that in this present
world the moral individual often fares
badly while the immoral individual often
flourishes but the intermediate state of
an imperfect morality which has shown
itself to be the essential one clearly
shows that this observation this
supposed experience is merely ad
assemblance of the true state of the
case for sense morality is imperfect
that is morality in fact is not what can
there be in the experience that morality
fares badly since at the same time it
has turned out that it is happiness
simply as such that is involved it is
evident that in making the judgment that
the immoral individual flourishes it was
not intended to imply that an injustice
occurred here the designation of an
individual as immoral necessarily Falls
away when morality in general is
imperfect and has therefore only an
arbitrary basis therefore the sense and
content of the judgment of experience is
solely this that happiness simply as
such should not have been a lot of some
individuals that is the judgment is an
expression of envy which covers itself
with the cloak of morality the reason
however why so-called good luck should
fall to the lot of others is good
friendship which grants and wishes them
and itself to this lucky chance
here in paragraph 625 we see Hegel once
again grappling with this as he's
calling it intermediate position this
intermediate movement between the two
poles of an immoral or purely naturally
oriented human comportment one that is
concerned primarily for one's own
happiness and focuses on that and is
only interested in morality insofar as
being a good boy or girl will lead to
you know avoiding punishment and
enjoying rewards which is from you know
the moral point of view not moral at all
right and at the other side we have this
perfectly moral which we see Hegel
talked about earlier as lying in a
beyond that really took us beyond the
intelligibility of what that would would
comprise and in between we have the poor
human being the the rest of us who are
striving to be moral striving to fulfill
our duties striving to master or at
least grapple with our inclinations
desires and impulses and not allow them
to draw us entirely away from the moral
but it's imperfectly moral right so what
do we make of this now Hegel says the
second aspect of the moral view of the
world by this second aspect the other
assertion of the first aspect in which
the disharmony the disjunction the lack
of alignment between morality and
happiness is assumed winds up being
nullified winds up being taken beyond
winds up being incorporated right and he
says it's claimed and here we get this
this judgment that that we're going to
examine it's claimed that experience are
following the conduct of one's life
within the world right so going around
and seeing how things actually work its
claimed that experience
is us with a certain kind of judgment
one that we can trust what is it he says
experience shows that in this present
world a world in which morality and
Happiness do not coincide not only do
they not coincide we're confronted with
a scandal and this is not a new scandal
I mean you see this in the Psalms right
why is it that the wicked prosper and
grind the the just and the good into the
dust how long are you going to tolerate
this Oh Lord that's the way one of the
Psalms runs and there are complaints
like this over and over and over again
the moral individual the more Alicia the
the person who is motivated by morality
fairs badly you know literally it goes
badly for them right select and then the
immoral individual as the translation
has it here flourishes googley gaya
right things go happily for them things
go fortunately for them and how many
examples could we come up with or dwell
on we only need to look at a few I mean
think about how it works in the world
that we experience is everybody who does
the right thing rewarded for doing the
right thing sometimes they are and
sometimes they're not and sometimes the
reward is a mere pittance they're just
trying to buy you off to get you to shut
up and get out of there so they don't
have to deal with their guilty
consciences quite often doing the wrong
thing does in fact pay off within the
currency of the world sometimes when you
do the right thing the bonus that you
get is more work more right things to do
oh you're you're motivated by duty
you're motivated by doing the right
thing by other people well we'll give
you plenty of that to deal with and
we'll give you nothing in return because
as we know virtue is its own reward
you know the way
of goodness are simply the act itself
and that's the way it actually does work
quite often in the world isn't it so
this is a judgment that the person is
making and then he says the intermediate
state of an imperfect morality which is
shown itself to be the essential one the
important one the visa bleakest right
clearly shows that this observation this
suppose that experience this judgment is
a decembe once of the true state of the
case there is a certain truth to it
right there's a certain very similar to
truthiness it would be a nice way that
people talk about it today you're having
sort of the aspect of truth without
actually being true that's what was
meant in earlier times by vir similar to
right a similarity to the true and this
decembe once does have something of that
because it's not completely off right it
does conform to the world but it's not
the whole story so he co goes on and he
says it shows that this is a dissemblers
of the true state of the case what is
the true state of the case because
morality is imperfect in person who is
striving the person who is trying the
person who is attempting to be moral
Hegel says morality strictly speaking is
not not what it's not morality it
doesn't really exist so if that's the
case he says what can there be in the
experience that morality fares badly
it's not like morality itself embodied
in the moral individual is faring badly
morality is doing just fine being
morality it's the moral individual for
whom these conditions are not returning
a dividend are not paying off and you
know like like we just said maybe you
can say to them well you know you said
virtues its own rewards so what are you
so bent out of shape about he goes on
and he says
at the same time it's turned out that
happiness simply as such that is
involved it is evident that in making
the judgment that the immoral individual
flourishes it was not intended to imply
that an injustice occurred here so we
have two different ways of looking at
this this state of affairs the fact that
morality and happiness don't coincide
and often seem to be in opposition or
disharmony with each other when we look
at the lives of particular individuals
we can look at it and say this is a
travesty this is not the way things
ought to be the world ought to be fair
or we could say well Who am I to say
that the world in fact ought to be fair
when I'm not myself moral what would be
motivating a person to get so worked up
about this as so many people do write
often selectively they they're they're
worried about some moral individuals
getting the short end of the stick but
not all of them right and they're
worried about some dirty rotten
scoundrels getting the bag of gold at
the end but not all of them if it
happens to be the ones as Hegel's gonna
talk about friends if it happens to be
their cronies if it happens to be their
political accomplices if it happens to
be the people who look like them share
the same ideology they're probably okay
with that so long as they get a cut it's
when somebody else gets away with it
that they have such a big problem right
so he goes on and he says it's evident
that in making the judgment that the
immoral individual flourishes it was not
intended to imply there's an injustice
the designation of an individual as
immoral necessarily falls away when
morality in general is imperfect and
therefore has only an arbitrary basis
this is something a lot of people forget
they act as if they're over here they
are perfectly moral they embody you know
the fulfillment of duty the development
of virtue whatever it is
we want to say and they forget the fact
that they are just miserable bastards
like the rest of us who are striving to
do a little bit better with themselves
and often failing and if they did that
then they would be a lot less upset
about this because they would say well
what am i doing that's actually fixing
this within the world did I in fact
reward the moral individual and you know
take something away from the immoral
individual or am i part of this this
same process and problem so he goes on
and he says the sense and the content of
the judgment of experience is simply
this that happiness simply as such
should not have been the law of some
individuals again there's a
particularities
so he says the judgment is an expression
of something else Envy
neide this knowing at you seeing
somebody else prosper who you feel
doesn't have a right to do that because
they're not a good person like you this
is not very far away from what Nietzsche
later on down the line is going to call
slave or herd morality is it the
transvaluation of values that he thinks
is in fact not only shot through but
with rosante month but filled with envy
but we can put that aside for the moment
where is Hegel going with this he says
that the judgment is an expression of
envy and it covers itself with a cloak
of morality the reason here's where the
really interesting ending is the reason
why so so-called good luck should fault
of a lot of others is what good
friendship which grants and wishes them
in itself to this lucky chance why is it
that that the the immoral individual
does flourish well because the amoral
individual is able to get along with
other people they're not a
stick-in-the-mud people actually like
them for whatever reason is flawed and
screwed up as they are and they
or them with some degree of happiness
and you can choose how you want to
approach that you can get envious about
that and say why are they enjoying that
happiness I should enjoy that happiness
or you can say well that is in fact the
way this world does seem to work and
it's very arbitrary where the happiness
winds up going and it's arbitrary
because it here's the thing arbitrary in
German Wilk er right it depends on the
will of others not just on one's own
will sort of extended out to the entire
universe
morality then in the moral consciousness
is imperfect this is now what is put
forward but it is the essence of
morality to be only the perfectly pure
imperfect morality is therefore impure
or is immorality morality itself thus
exists in another being than the actual
consciousness this other being is a holy
moral lawgiver the imperfect morality
and consciousness which is the reason
for making these postulates means in the
first instance that morality when it is
posited in consciousness as actual
stands in relation to and other to in
existence and therefore itself receives
within it other Nisour difference giving
rise to a whole variety of moral laws
the moral self consciousness at the same
time however holds these many duties to
be uh nacelle for it is concerned only
with the one pure duty and the many have
no truth for it insofar as they are
specific duties they can therefore have
their truth only in another being and
are made sacred which they are not for
the moral consciousness by a holy
lawgiver but this again is only ad
assemblance of the real position for the
moral self-consciousness is its own
absolute and duty is absolutely only
what it knows is duty but duty it knows
only as pure duty what is not sacred for
it is not sacred in itself and what is
not in itself sacred cannot be made
sacred by the holy being the moral
consciousness - is not really an earnest
about letting something be sacred by
another consciousness than itself
for that alone it holds to be sacred
which it has itself made sacred and is
sacred in it it is therefore just as
little in earnest about the holiness of
this other being for in this something
was supposed to obtain an essential 'ti
which for the moral consciousness that
is in itself it did not possess
now in paragraph 626 Hegel again is
going to explore what the status of this
imperfectly moral and therefore immoral
existing actual human being is in
relation to other human beings and in
relation to whatever it is that would be
perfectly moral which he's going to call
here a holy moral law Giver and you can
think of that as God if you like or some
sort of transcendental ideal and there's
a type of dissemblers that's still going
on in this a form of self-deception
a form of not quite having fixed upon
what the answer is so Hegel begins again
we're talking about this this imperfect
morality says morality in the moral
consciousness moral consciousness of a
actually existing acting human being is
imperfect this is now what is put
forward this is what we're admitting to
and then he says well we've got a
problem here and this is one that he's
brought up before the essence of
morality is to be perfectly pure to be
realized as entire perfective right
so he says imperfect morality is
therefore actually immoral and this
isn't completely new we've mentioned
this several times before but now we're
going to draw out a important corollary
to this imperfect morality is itself
immorality so where where does morality
exist then he says it exists in another
being than the actual consciousness so
we've talked about it existing in this
beyond but it has to exist in a being
that is at least postulated at least
thought as having a sort of agency as
having a sort of activity as having
something like us so what
we conceived of this holy moral lawgiver
as being I mean one traditional way of
conceiving this is of God right and
that's the way traditional monotheism
has regarded whatever it is that's truly
good right you can find all sorts of
biblical passages only God is truly good
right and that's one possibility another
would be some sort of transcendent ideal
conte brings up in religion within the
limits of reason alone the idea of a
perfectly holy will a will that would
always do the the right thing would have
the right motivation in every case
obviously not us right and that could be
along the same lines and we might think
of other things to fill in that that gap
as well and no you know we're going to
talk about the other in just a bit but
you might think of the other that we're
going to talk about as human beings as a
lower case all other and this is the
capital o other right the truly other to
ourselves and if we jump forward in time
to say somebody like you know Rudolf
Otto with his phenomenology of the Holy
what's-what's really you know core to
that the experience of the absolutely
other to ourselves and then we can jump
to levy NOS and other people along those
lines and it's really about the same
sort of issue now he goes on and he says
this other being is a holy moral
lawgiver so the imperfect morality in
consciousness which is the reason for
making these postulates what what how is
the imperfect being the reason for
making these postulates well we're
trying to think through these conundrums
that are arising where we're trying to
deal with an imperfectly moral being
that is morally motivated but not enough
to actually be moral in a full sense we
somehow morality is haunting this
grood up world that we see were you know
it appears that everything is driven by
nature and striving after happiness so
where is there room for morality in all
of this right so he goes on and he says
this means in the first instance that
morality when posited in consciousness
is actual stands in relation to and
other we find our duty orienting us
towards another and the morality if it
doesn't exist in us maybe it exists in
that other now can we get that from
other human beings
no Hegel says we cannot at this point
why because it stands in relation to
another to an existence and therefore
itself receives within itself other Ness
and difference giving rise to a whole
variety of moral laws and you could
think about all the determinate ways in
which you are related to other people
within your small circuit of friends and
family and co-workers and colleagues and
neighbors and all the myriad duties that
you have to these different people and
then think about the duties you have to
people on the internet or to people that
you haven't yet met all these specific
duties people that you ride the the
subway with or you know that you're
driving on the same roads with you have
duties to them as well when you when you
think about it it actually makes your
head kind of spin doesn't it
now these duties are not really going to
work here though for morality says the
moral self-consciousness holds these
many duties to be uh nacelle
there they are duties but they're uh
nacelle they're not revealing the nature
of morality to it because it is
concerned with the one pure duty and the
many don't have truth for it insofar as
their specific duties he's not saying
that they don't they're not duties he's
not saying that they have no importance
he's saying that they can't lead us to
the result that we want which is well
where the hell is morality if it's not
in me we
this perfect lawgiver and what duties do
I have to them so he goes on he says
they can therefore have their truth only
at another being and are made sacred but
which they are not for the moral
consciousness by who by a holy law giver
the holy law giver is the one who says
don't cut off your neighbor in traffic
right making it impossible for them to
reach their off-ramp and exit from the
highway you know you could have
simplified it and says do thou shalt not
be a jerk
and when driving all right don't lock
your horn at pedestrians to tell them to
get the hell out of the intersection
when they're trying to cross now you
could say well you could recognize that
you have a duty to them just as an other
but it helps if you have the holy moral
lawgiver to say this is how you're
supposed to treat other human beings so
he goes on he says this is only ad
assemblance however of the real position
why because moral self-consciousness is
its own absolute and duty is absolutely
only what it knows as duty and here
there's an interesting twist that's
occurring right he says but duty it
knows only as pure duty what is not
sacred for it is not sacred in itself so
if the holy moral lawgiver is not sacred
in itself in such a way that makes it
sacred for me but I'm the one who's
actually making it sacred then it's not
really sacred and I can't rely upon it
as a guide even though I'm pretending
like I should do that and this raises a
conundrum well wait a second so I knew I
didn't have morality and me so it's not
in these other people and it's not in
the holy law giver where the hell is it
this is one of the fundamental questions
that this question that the section is
grappling with and that morality the
moral consciousness is engaging in
dissembling sore self-deception
throughout this entire time about so he
says
you know what is not an in itself sacred
cannot be a it made sacred by the holy
being so the moral consciousness and
notice one more time is not in earnest
it has been self deceiving right it is
not in earnest about letting something
be made sacred by another consciousness
than itself for that alone it holds to
be sacred which it has itself made
sacred and is sacred in it so he says
it's therefore just as little an
earnestness about the holiness of this
other being the other being being the
holy moral lawgiver for in this
something was supposed to obtain an
essential 'ti which for the moral
consciousness that is in itself it did
not possess so what we've got going on
here Hegel's pointing out is a kind of
playing around with displacing the you
know you might say the moral weight of
morality a perfected morality we're you
know postulating this ideal beyond us
out in some sort of beyond that is not
fully intelligible which we're trying to
imagine trying to try to you know use
but it's really us doing this the entire
time so if if we don't really have the
moral standpoint within ourselves how
the hell does it wind up out there in
this absolute lawgiver that's the
question that were left with at this
point
you